よろしくお願いします
この仏弟子たちの歌っていうのは最高でしょうね
で これすごい長いんですからね
まああのそのまま中村先生の翻訳をね
佐藤健三さんに打ってもらったんです
私が自分で打つならば日日間ぐらいかかるんです
ね で  レーワタ長老とゴーダッタ長老
ですね レーワタ長老のあの本名はカディラバニヤ・レーワタという名前なんですね
カディラバニヤっていうのは住んでいた場所の名前で
これは森なんですね ずっとこの森に住んでいた
阿羅漢で お釈迦様がこの倫理なんていう倫教というお坊さんたちが一般人々がいるところに住むか
全く人々から離れて人が来ない
行かない森に住むかって
どちらかに住むところを決めるんですね
好みによって その中でこの森を選んだお坊さんとして
このレーワタ長老がお釈迦様からこの称号までもらっているんですね
第一人者であると かなりの
大変なお坊様ですね この長老はについてはいくらかの結構ストーリーありましてね
なんか私の主観的な判断でちょっと合わないところもありましたりして
だからまあ省略して言います
これはあのサーリプッタ尊者
知恵の第一人者と証拠をもらっているサーリプッタ尊者の弟なんですね
末っ子ですよ 一番下の弟なんです
で サーリプッタ尊者のお母さんが
まあ仏教って名前を聞いただけでも腹が立って非難
侮辱する女性なんですね
ものすごいお金のある方でしたけどね
絶対仏教大嫌いで 徹底してバラモン教
ヒンドゥー教を信仰しているんですね
この恨み理由がありまして
すごい奥さん長者で 全て息子たちも娘さんたちもみんな出家してしまったんです
サーリプッタ長老が長男なんですね
だから財産を跡継ぎになるでしょうと思っていたのに
出て行って 次の次から次からみんな出家しちゃったんです
だからものすごいもう怒っているんです
で お坊さんたちそこら辺にいたっても
托鉢も何もしません 追い出すんです
そこでこのレーワタ長老が一番末っ子でちっちゃかったんです
年齢ちょっとなんか合わないなと思いますけどね
で お母さんが考えたのは
インドでは子供が生まれた時に結婚させることがあるんですね
だから結婚っていうのは何歳からって決まってないんです
赤ちゃん同士で結婚させることもあります
で まあそれはバラモン教
ヒンドゥー教のしきたりでね
というか インド人のしきたりですよ
宗教にはそんなことは書いてないんですけどね
カースト制度をね すごい厳しく頑張ってるんですけど
まあ本当にそんなに厳しくカースト制度を語ってないんです
ヒンドゥー教の宗教の本では宗教でない文学作品である
あの 何て言ったってバガヴァッドギーター
あれはひとかけらの宗教書じゃないんだけどね
みんな世界的にあれは素晴らしいブッダのブッダの法華経と指摘する素晴らしい作品だと
文学作品として素晴らしいんです
それはもう問題ないんですね
宗教書として消灯したら最低なんです
まあとにかくそういうところでカースト制度をあれこれ喋ってるんですけど
文学作品での社会システムもそのまま現れ説明するストーリーですからね
はい とにかく だからこの何歳でも結婚できるんですね
この長老がその七歳の時
お母さんがものすごい他のそれ家柄のね
適したバラモン系の家のところに結婚式を挙げたんだと
そこでまあ結婚するお嫁さんの家で式を挙げなくちゃいけないんですね
大体結婚式はまあお嫁さんの家でやるんです
そこでこの子供を大げさな行列で連れて行って
そこで結婚式挙げて そうするとこの女の子はそれからあの家に戻るんだから
男の子の家に だからみんなこの女の子に祝福するんですね
祝福する時はもうあなたはこのひいおばあちゃん
ひいおばあちゃんですかね
おばあちゃんのお母さんがひいおばあちゃんぐらい長生きしてくださいと
みんな祝福するんですね
長生きします ひいおばあちゃんぐらいとかね
そしたら子供がね 女の子はひいおばあちゃんくらい長生きするんだから
それはどんな人ですかと
聞いたら式に来てないんだと
見たいんだと 言ったら
まあどうせサーリプッタ尊者の家は格が上ですからね
言ったらこのひいおばあちゃん連れてきたんですね
なんとか何とか支えて
ものすごく骨と皮だらけで
ものすごいもう見ていられない状態でボロボロなんですね
あまりにも年取っちゃって
一二〇歳は超えているんです
だからもう言葉 言葉が聞こえない
私同じくね 今大変です
それ見たらものすごく
なんだこれと この子は
この人ここまでなるのかとびっくりしちゃって
その場であの女の子のこと
あの生命体のこと すごく嫌になっちゃったんですね
この生命体っていうのは
こんな風にものすごい醜い
ものすごい大変なところまで進むことであると
もう嫌ですよ でもどうした？しょうがないんですよ
もう引き上げて これは大変なことになっちゃったと
そうすると ちっちゃい時は子供二人が遊んでるだけなんですけど
それでも自分と一緒に家に住んでね
遊んでくれる同じ年の子供を見る度に
あのおばあちゃんの画像が思い浮かぶんだからね
これは子供にとってはなかなか大変きついんですね
だから逃げなくちゃいけないと思ったんです
そこでもたくさんの人々で
行列でいっぱい馬車があってね
並べて行くんだから逃げる方法なくて
で 森のところに来たんですね
道 森抜けたら当然みんなだけで
あの止めてくださいと
子供だから当然おしっこですね
止めてください すぐ行ってきますと
これこう降りて そのまま逃げたんです
逃げて逃げて行く みんなじーっと待っていて
そろそろ帰るけど帰らない
もう帰らないんだから
ちょっと捜しても 捜す時はもうとっくに逃げてるんです
そこで逃げて逃げてどこかで森の中で何か人が住んでるようなところが坊さんたちですけどね
で そちらに入って入ったんですね
入って おそらく偉大なるお兄様のことも知ってるでしょう
だからこの偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者も
この子も結局は出家するんだと
家がそれでもう全て破壊されるの知っていたんです
みんな逃げ出す逃げ出す
お母さんまで後でギリギリのところでね
ギリギリのところで仏教に興味を持ったんです
で サーリプッタ尊者がこのそこら辺の全部情報知ってるんだから
そこら辺の森に住んでるお坊さんたちに
うちの息子 あの弟が来たら出家させなさいと
親の許可は要りませんと
これは長男だからね で
親の許可は要りません
そのまま出家したかったら出家させてくださいと
そしたらまあ子供だったら親が許可しなきゃできませんしね
それでこのケースの場合は親の許可は要りませんと言われているんだから
先に出家願する前からも許可を得てるんです
それで出家させたんですね
で そこでこのサーリプッタ尊者にその情報が入って
さっさと弟に会いたくなったんですね
サーリプッタ尊者もすごいから子供にものすごい優しいんですよ
で 自分のところにもちっちゃなサミたちをいっぱい住んでいたし
教育を受けてたし だから連れてきたかったんですね
自分のところに お釈迦様はちょっと待ちなさいと
言ったら 私の今の弟子と違って
お釈迦様の弟子たちは言うことは聞く
私の弟子たちは言ったらそちらの反対
頑固でやるんです だからこれから弟子たちが反対のことを言うかなと
で お釈迦様が待ちなさいと言ったところでまあ待っていたんですね
この子供もサミもあの弟が来るだろう
来る弟や姉さんが来るだろう来るだろうと待っていたんですけど
来る気配もないし ですからしょうがない
出家したんだから修行するんだということで
そのお坊さんたちから教えてもらって
修行して悟りに達するんです
阿羅漢になるんです それでお釈迦様がこの
サーリプッタ尊者に私も行くんだからね
弟に会いに行きましょう
お釈迦様がこれは大きな大騒ぎの出来事にしちゃったんです
ちょっとこそこそと弟さんに会いにいくことではなくて
500人ぐらい阿羅漢たち
アーナンダ尊者 大阿羅漢たち
みんな呼んでみんなで一緒に行きましょうと
だからまあ お釈迦様はお釈迦様はケースをすごい大事にしているんですね
サーリプッタ尊者があまりにも謙虚で
もう自分と同じく弟も社会に出せないだろうと思いますね
そこをお釈迦様は意趣をかけて
じゃああんた弟に会って会ってないで
じゃあ会いに行きましょうよと
私も行きますからとお釈迦様は来ないでくださいと言えないんだからね
現代人と違いますからね
仏教だったらダメって言うんだからね
まあそこでまあ 500人ぐらい阿羅漢たち
大阿羅漢たちを率いて行くんです
で これかなり田舎で森なんですね
そこで森に入る道2つに2つに分かれる
1つは恐ろしい森を通していかなくちゃいけない
一人の人間もそこら辺に住んでない
もう一つ道があって まあ 1ヶ月間ぐらいかかりますけど
町 町 町でなんとか森に入られる
この森はこのカディラワニカディラ罠なんでカディラっていうか植物なんですね
これはかなりきついトゲがある植物で
この英語の単語はこのアカシアかな
アカシアはネットで調べましたけど
いろんな種類がありまして
面倒くさくてやめたんですね
で オーストラリア原産たり
あるいはこれは南アメリカと言ったり
インドのタイプのアカシアがありまして
それはこのトゲとかあることでは有名なんですね
ウジキソウと同じ植物種類ですから
ウジキソウには怖いトゲがあるんですね
なんかザーッとそれはあるんだから
なかなか人々には出会い難しいんです
そこで 34順  30里でしたっけね
この短い道で行けば このこれはアナンダ尊者が言うんで
お釈迦様はここ道に入っちゃうと人間には会いませんと
お坊さんたちは即座にしなくちゃいけないし
こちらからはまあ 1ヶ月ぐらいかかりますけど
ずっと道があって 安全で泥棒もなくて
もう何もなくて 悪霊もなくて大丈夫やと
お釈迦様はこの森の道
この道だったらまあまあまあ 30里で
順で でもこれは人は入らないんだよと
それお釈迦様がこのグループの中でシーバリ尊者とかいますか？と
なんとかなんとかいますよと
じゃあだったらこちらから行きましょうと
それで短い道を選んだんですね
だからそこはまあまあちょっとストーリーだけの味が落ちるところなんですけど
サーリプッタシーバリ尊者っていうのは
ものすごいこのお布施いただく徳があるんですね
どこに行っても もう何人分でも食事のお布施をいただくんです
だからものすごい徳が高いんですね
お釈迦様がウジキ尊者に与えてくるって
ちょっとちょっと話にならんだけどね
本当は お釈迦様のところの方がもっとすごいんですから
とにかくこの弟子たちをハイライトしたいというストーリーですからね
で 森に入ったら もうシーバリ尊者やら阿羅漢というものに入ったら
この悪霊やら夜叉たちがみんなもう避けましたと
それから神々来て ちゃんと道で食事を用意して
みんなの食事を そうしてあげたんだと
だから無事何の問題もなく森にこのカディレ
カディレワナのところにアカシアの森に入るんです
それでレイワタ長老はお釈迦様が来るんだと
サーリプッタ尊者と一緒に
じゃあお接待しなくちゃいけないということで
自分があらかんてすごい超能力
神通持ってるんですね
そこでこの 自分がものすごい質素な苦しい生活をしているということで心配したら困ると
だって恐ろしい彼の道の向こうでしょうに
だからこんな生活するんじゃなくて
お釈迦様や比丘尼僧侶のところに行きましょうと連れて行かれるんですね
ですから 本人が何したんですかと
すごい豪華なお寺を自分の神通で作っちゃったんです
それでレイワタ長老も
まあ阿羅漢ですけど 住んでるところもかなり立派で
お坊さんたちがものすごく「すごいところですね
大臣ですね」とかね びっくりしちゃって
そこで 一ヶ月間ぐらいお釈迦様が泊まっていたんですね
とにかくお釈迦様がすごい特別扱いするんですね
この方を 一ヶ月間そちらでいて
じゃあ帰りましょう 今日いろいろ調べたところで見つからなかったんだけど
自分のスリランカで勉強した時あったことで
この帰る時はまあ あのアカシアの森を出た途端
あのレイワタ尊者が神通力を話しちゃったんですね
また険しい怖い森に戻ったんです
それで一人にお坊さんが何か忘れ物があって
自分のあの御簾なんですね
それは必ず持っていかなくちゃ
忘れちゃって ああ 私の御簾忘れちゃったからそれ持ってきますと
置いた場所を知ってますよと
行ったらあのお寺大臣がいない
ないんです え？どういうことかと
で すごく困っちゃって
あちらこちら見ているところで
自分の御簾はこの木の枝に棘の引っかかっちゃったところにぶら下がってるんですね
そこをすごい怪我もしながらそれ取って戻ったんですけど
そこでこのレイワタ尊者が住んでるところについては
なんか互い違い噂流れるんですね
一部はもう素晴らしいとこだよ
なんて美しい贅沢なところでしょう
もうとんでもないところだとかね
とにかくそのすごい険しいところに住んでるんだっていう話があって
このお坊さんたち 阿羅漢たち人行って
彼らは素晴らしいところと言うんですね
だからそこはレイワタ長老のからくりっていうことを知らなかったんですね
だからまあなんで互い違い噂二つ流れるのかというね
ストーリーあって そこでまあウィサーカ夫人がね
どういう言葉でお釈迦に聞いたかとか
それもそれについてもいろいろ説法なさって
そういうのはいろんなところで記録されてはいます
そこで後でこのレイワタ尊者がやったことは
自分のお姉ちゃんの息子が何て言いますか
甥？いいね  3人の甥がいたんですね
娘2人がいたので あの
お母様に男上の2人と最後の男も逃げちゃったしね
娘が2人がいた 2人は уже出家してたんです
娘が3人 チャーラ ウパチャーラ
シシュウパチャーラという名前なんですね
3人目出家しちゃったんです
これは腹が立つでしょうね
でっかいお城に一人でいるんだから
召使いと一緒に 何の面白くもないんで
この人があの甥3人連れて行っちゃって出家された
そこもなくなっちゃったんです
じゃあ娘3人の子供がいるんだからといって楽しいでしょうしね
これもできなかった だからそこぞと話してて
それでいて出家されたんです
それでそちらの3人の指導はレイワタ大長老がやっているんですね
で それでまたサーリプッタ尊者が気になって様子を見に来るんですね
様子を見に来ると この人がサーリプッタ尊者が来るんだからね
上の叔父さんでしょ ちょっとでも間違ったことを
儀式でも間違ったらものすごい大変だということで
厳しく躾をさせておいたんですね
サーリプッタ尊者が来たらすごく丁寧で行者もよく知っていて
よく修行しているんですね
そしたらよく頑張っているんだと
じゃあこれからも指導お願いしますということで心配しないで尊者が帰るんですね
で ちょっと合わないストーリーがありまして
この長老がどうしても森森が好みで
森にしか住まない たまたまブッダに会いたいんだからね
ブッダに会うためにサイジョンには行く
サイジョンっていうのは巨大な街なんです
都会なんです そちらに行っても
お釈迦様と一緒に話して
全部終わって夜になっちゃうと
どかの森に行って夜過ごすんです
それでサイジョーにいた時は
この長老がもう夜森の中にもう人が入らないくらいの中に入って
夜そちらにいる で 泥棒たちが強盗をやって品物を持って
この森を通して 強盗たちが森に住むんだからね
王さんたちと強盗仲間ですからね
森に住んでるんだから
まあそこを間違えて何か品物一つを失っちゃったんですね
だからこの後 強盗されたということをわかって
この出て行った道がわかるんですね
足跡が それで王様のあの連中がね
警察が行って行ってみたら
もう盗品見つけて あ 一つあるんだと
そこら辺 レイワタ長老が禅定に入ってるんですね
レイワタ長老を捕まって捕まったんだと
これどう見てもおかしい話ですけど
まあ向こうの方々 あまり疑わないんですね
だからいくらなんでも
もしレイワタ長老が強盗したらば
強盗した品物をそばにドカーンと胸張っているわけないでしょうに
もう警察が来る時は 捕まって王様のところに連れて王様
様には私はもう品物を盗む人じゃありませんと言って
ずっと自分弁解しなくちゃかんだからね
まあ芸で弁解したんだと
そこはこのテーラワーダの一部になっているみたいですね
そこでこの自分の無罪を訴えるというよりも
仏教を語っていて それで最後に私はこれで涅槃に入るでしょうと言って
その場であの自分の神通の力で体そのまま詠唱して涅槃に入れたと
そんなことが起きてならば
他のところでも記録あるはずなんですけど
それほど目に入らないんだからね
1か所でしかないんですね
こんな まあどれも伝説をいろいろ組み合わせて組み合わせてストーリー作るし
どこかにあのカディラマニやレイワタ長老の物語っていう風にまとめたところはないんです
いろんなところで一部一部キャラで出てくるだけ
だからあまり お互い合わないところはあるんですね
だからお釈迦様の生涯も誰もずっと隠すつもりはなかったんです
だから何か出来事で その時やったことだけ記録する
だからライフストーリーを作る人々が大変全て調べて調べて
これどんな年齢も考えて順番つけたりして
これは大変な作業で それでも完全なストーリーが現れないんです
どんなあれかにしたっても
お釈迦様にしても これは大きな問題で
ブッダチャリタはお釈迦様の生涯物語はもう結構興味あるんだからみんな作りましたけどね
でもパーリ経典では半分しかない
それでサンスカリト語でブッダチャリタという
これも随分後でまぁ  1世紀あたりかな
もうちょっと前かな 素晴らしい文学作品がありましてね
そこはもうものの見事にブッダの生涯を書かれているんですね
この世の中に存在する人間というものではなくて
すごい美しく書いているんですね
学問的にはね 事実ならないものも結構ありますけどね
そういうことで このレーワッタ長老に対しても
ちょっと合わないいくつかのエピソードが出ているんですね
それから その長老のもう一つの特色は
この 喋りたくない なんか出国の弟子たちはあまり喋れないみたいですね
それも私にかかってくるんだから
喋りばっかりだからね
出来が悪いということは何のことなく証明されている
で で お釈迦様に褒められると褒められる弟子たちはあまり喋れません
そこで この在家の信者さんの中で
この超エリートの信者さんがいて
アトゥラという名前の
おっかない知恵な知識と知恵なんですね
まぁ預流果か一来果までは悟ってもいましたし
お坊さんたちでも困るんで
この在家の人と喋る場合は
あるいはこれは質問するんだけど
お坊さんたちもよくわからない
わからない場合はお坊さんたちに教えてあげる
これはこういうことで
これはこういうことだとかね
なんか出家して なんかちょっと在家の人に教えてもらっていると
ちょっとなんかお坊さんたちがあまりいい気にはならないんですね
まぁ それでもお釈迦様に褒められている在家信者でしょうし
お布施もお布施はします
ちゃんとお坊さんたちの面倒は丁寧に見てあげている
しかし 丁寧に面倒見たりとか
家に食事に行ったら 食事終わったら
ほら なんだこれどうと質問する
それは本当に自分の知ったかぶりを言うためではなくて
やっぱりまだ悟りに達していないお坊さんたちをちょっと応援するために
いろんなことを教えてあげて協力してあげなくちゃいけない
そういう意味で とにかくレーワッタ尊者はすごい方だと分かったところで
自分が勉強してもらえると思って
このサイジョンにいる時はアトゥラさんが自分が頭大きい金持ちの人で
みんなでグループで行ったんですね
言って長老に何か弟子とか説法等も聞きたいんだけど
一言葉喋れなかったんです
それですごい機嫌が悪くなっちゃって帰ったそうです
またいろいろエピソードありましてね
森に住んでるでしょうね
だから大長老でしょうし
お釈迦様からね 称号位ももらってるお坊さんだから
これ 80人しかいないんでしょ？だからそちらいろいろな人々がいて弟子入りするんです
だから森にまあずっとこの長老が森の中で瞑想禅定に入っているんですね
修行いつでも瞑想している
もう一人がお坊さんがいて
もう一生懸命掃除するんですね
いつ見ても手に箒があるんですね
もう綺麗にして綺麗にして
まあそれも戒律の一つなんですけど
ちゃんと作務やらなくちゃいけないんですね
お坊さんたち住んでるところはものすごく綺麗に掃除して整理整頓して行かなくちゃいけないんですね
ピッタシと だから自分がすごい頑張って精進して
このお捨ての戒律を負っているんだ
朝早く起きてちゃんと掃除をして
托鉢に来て行って帰ったらまた汚れてるんだ
から葉っぱ落ちたりとかね
また綺麗に掃除して またちょっとやんだらまた森の中だからね
また汚れちゃうし それでまた入るところあれしてまた掃除をする
レーワッタ長老は何もしない
そこであなたも出家だからね
怠けでばっかしどういうことかと
修行に励んだらどうですかと
霊鷲掌炉に怒ったんです
言ったら霊鷲掌炉は漢訳教えてあげて
いい加減にしろよと で
仏道はそんなもんじゃないんだということで
やっぱりそれであの人は謝ったんですね
この人は大阿羅漢でね
そこは阿羅漢になるまで導くことは仕事であって
それは修行であって 掃除するかしないかとあまり関係ないということでね
そういう風にいろいろエピソードがあります
じゃあ私たちのお話に行きましょう
やだアハンパッバジトアガーラスマアナガリヤンナアビジャナミサンカッパンアナリヤンドーササンヒタン
で これあの最後の言葉ですから
どう説明しましょうか
私が出家して家に住む状態から家のない状態に入った時に
私は増悪伴った卑しい意向思考を持つことはなかった
意向ですね  ん？ 卑しい意向ですね
意向 なかった で あの 行目であるのはね
サンカッパンというのは考え
思考ですよ アナリヤンドーササンヒタン
アナリヤンというのは聖者にふさわしくない
あのドーサというのは怒り
嫌な気持ち 嫌な気持ちに伴った思考というのは一切受けていないんだと
出家してから だからそのまま出家したでしょう
子供の頃 出家してその瞬間からあの
この嫌ですよ こんなのは嫌という
この怒りに関わる微妙にでも思考が起きたことがないんだと
イメーハンニャントゥワッジャントゥドゥッカンパッポントゥパーニノーサンカッパンナアビジャナメーマスミンディーガマンテレー私はこの長い時期の間
これらの生き物は殺されよう
殺す  殺戮ですね  殺戮されよう
苦しみに遭うようにという意向を持つことはなかった
なんかそんなことないでしょ
誰だってねって思うでしょうね
これは日本訳のせいで
で パーリ語ではもっと文化的な意味があって
バラモン教では生贄をするんですね
だからこの何頭の山羊を殺しますか
何頭のヒツジを殺しますかとかね
それはすごく喜んで喋るんですね
すごい尊い気持ちで 神のために儀式をやらなくちゃいけない
では 今年の儀式どうしましょうかね
何頭にしましょうか 去年は十頭だからね
もうちょっと派手に五十頭見つかりましょうよとか
そんな感じなんですね
だからその場合は バラモン宗だけじゃなくて
教える人々もこの まあ何匹殺すかと考えなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そのような気持ちは起こったことはないんだ
それで森の中に住んでると蚊が来るわ
いろんなね 蛇がいるわ
どうしたっても もうごっつい森に住んでると動物殺す気になるんです
だから森の中であらゆる生命体が来て邪魔したり刺したり
いろいろあったでしょうに
でもこいつはもうパチってやりたいとかね
それは微妙にもそういう気持ちは生まれなかったと
ということは すごいこの本来的に生命に対してすごい優しさが合ったんですね
おかしい 慈しみとは一体になった存在
メッタンチャアビジャナーミ アッパマーナン スーバービタン アヌブッバン パリチタン ヤター ブッデーナ デーシタン
メッタンチャアビジャナーミ 自分が慈悲
慈しみをね アビジャナーミで知っている
ただ知ってるだけじゃない
choice と知恵でも経験している
慈しみというのは 私は生命に優しい
そんな程度じゃないんです
かなり四六時中生命に対して優しいっていうことを体験的に持っているんです
アッパマーナン スーバービタン
アッパマーナンというのは
生命は あの えっとえっと
リミットしませんね 生命なら誰でもということで
自分と一緒の命として見ているんですね
だから頑張って見てるんじゃなくて
その境地に入ってるんです
自分と一切の生命って同じ生命ということはもうじりじり感じているんです
これは瞑想の結果なんです
アヌブッバンパリチタンヤターブッデーナデーシタン
アヌブッバンパリチタン
順番で私はその修行しましたよと
ヤターブッデーナデーシタン
お釈迦様にこういう風に慈悲の瞑想しなさいと教えて教えられてますよ
この通りにやって皆様と違い
違いますね お釈迦様に教えられた通りに慈悲の瞑想をやってみましたと
これ中村先生の訳 しかし
私はブッダの説かれたように無量の慈しみをよく治め
順次に実践して積み重ねたのを知っている
サッバミットー サッバサコー サッバブータヌ カンプコ メッタチッタンチャ バーベーミ アッビャーパッジャラトー サダー
これは結構パーリ語的には美しい歌なんですね
サッバミットー すべての生命が私の友達である
サッバサコー みんな一切生命が私の仲間である
生命が仲間である サッバブータヌ カンプコ
すべての生き物のことを心配する
そのようにメッタチッタンチャ バーベーミ
慈悲の心を実践しますと
アッビャーパッジャラトー サダー
アッビャーパッジャラトー
害を与えないという 生命に幸福
至福を与えますけど 微妙にでも害は迷惑はかけませんということで
常に私はいるんだと 先生の訳
我は万人の友である ともである
万人の仲間である 一切の生きとし生けるものの同情者である
慈しみの心を修め 常に無障害無障害を楽しむ
この訳もなかなかいい訳ですね
なんかダブルになっちゃっちゃったんですね
アサンヒーラン アサンクッパン チッタン アモーダヤーマーン ブラーフマヴィハーラン バーベーミ アカプリシェナセ アカプリシェセビタン
パーリス整備丹って私はすごく問題だと思いますけど
学者は問題視していないんですね
私は心が動揺せず不動であるのを喜ぶ
私は悪人が実践することのない清らかな安住の境地を治める
中村先生の訳 私の訳は違います
アサンヒーラン アサンヒーランっていうのは無執着
愛着なんですよ こうやって取り物事
あ欲しい欲しいと サンヒーラテっていうのは
外にあるものを自分の方に引っ張ることなんです
いわゆる執着なんですね
だからこっちを私のもの
私のものというふうに
何事に際しても自分のものにするということは一切ない
アサンコッパンっていうのは
あっちあっち もういやいやいやとかね
追い出す 引くエネルギーと追い出すエネルギー
その両方がないんですね
ですからアサンコッパンの逆らう対立ということで
アサンヒーラっていうのは執着
掴む 握りしめるって意味なんですね
そこを 2つなくなってる私のチッタンアモーデヤミアハン
チッタンアモーデヤマハン
これ文法分析する チッタンアモーデヤミアハン
私は心を喜ばしてるんだと
ここでどんな風に喜べるのか
全ての生命に対して自分のものにしようということもないし
出て行けということもないし
対立がない だからそれは動揺しないようにと動揺していないように訳されてますね
動揺するのは当たり前なんですけど
どんな理由で動揺するのか
ちゃんと原因入ってるんです
動揺しないというふうに言うのは
アサンコッパンなんですね
アサンコッパンっていうのはちょっと興奮するって意味もあるんですね
だからそこで学者の方々言っちゃってるんです
イギリス協会で英訳すると
もうそういう訳しちゃったんだから
それから全てそれで もう一度考え直そうということはないんです
まあどちらが正しいか分からないんだけど
私はそういう勝手な人だから
私は自分の訳をつけます
そこでこのモーダディっていうのは慈悲喜捨の喜なんですね
だから慈 メッターを瞑想して超した境地に入っちゃって
カルナーを瞑想して超した境地になりまって
ムリターを実践して だからこれ 4つの瞑想なんです
私は一つで慈悲の瞑想と総括してるでしょう
だから専門的に瞑想する場合は
これは瞑想対象なんです
真剣にずっと朝から晩までずっとその気持ちを捨てなくちゃいけない
そうすると気持ちいい
四つ一緒に育てることができないんです
一つの気持ちを選んで
そこを自分と一体になるまでやるんです
例えばメッター友情を選んだら
生命は友人であって友であるということを気持ちをね
育てて育てて 生命の気配を感じると
友情の感じがすぐ生まれてくるようなところまで育てなくちゃいけない
この聖者は四つもやってるんですね
今三つまで説かれているんです
ムニター喜 慈悲喜捨の喜を私はこういう風にやっているんだと
だから喜の喜びの瞑想の場合はアサンヒーラン
アサンクパンということが必要なんですね
アモーデは生命に対して喜びを感じることですね
生命 そうすると意味が変わるんです
前は不動であるのを喜ぶ
私の訳はもうちょっと違うんです
ブラフマヴィハーラン ヴァーヴェーニ
先生の訳は清らかな安住の境地ですね
ブラフマヴィハーラっていうのは
お釈迦様がブラフマヴィハーラという言葉使ってますよ
慈悲喜捨の実践はブラフマヴィハーラであると
だから普通慈悲喜捨を実践しながら生活するならば
それはブラフマヴィハーラである
梵行 いわゆる梵天と同じ生き方
いわゆる梵天というのは
インド人にとっては創造した唯一の神なんです
神と同等の生き方であると
だからブラフマヴィハーラというのは慈悲喜捨の精神で生きることですね
次 聖なる沈黙 ウペッカーになるんです Avitakkaṃ
samāpanno sammā sambuddha sāvako ariyena tunhī bhāvena upeto hoti tāv
ade.えー何？尊き
全き 全き悟りを開いた人
いわゆるブッダのことですね
の弟子は 思慮のない境地に到達した
彼は尊い沈黙を常に身に具現している
具現している パーリ語より難しいね
サッマーサンブッダ 皆さんは知ってますよ
その言葉 正覚者ですね
サッマーサンブッダサーロコ
正覚者の弟子たち アヴィタッカンサマーパンノ
思考妄想しないという境地に達しましたと
その方が皆さんは分かりやすい
いくら頼んでもやってくれないでしょう
思考妄想してはいけませんと言ったら
はい 分かりましたと言って一生懸命思考妄想する
やめる努力はなし こちらではしっかりとその境地に達していますよ
思考妄想がなくなったら心はどんな状態？頭の中
沈黙なんです これは聖なる沈黙と言うんです
要するに悟りの境地なんです
心と脳細胞が止まっているんです
もう波は打たないんです
ですからアリーエナトゥンニーバーヴェーナ
聖なる沈黙で今いるんだと
そこでウペッカー 慈悲喜捨の捨ありますね
これ 捨と一緒に悟り一緒にしているんです
慈悲喜は別々で瞑想して
じゃあ全ての生命 それ以上何やるのかというと
まあ生命は生命と思わなきゃ方がいいんじゃないかなと思ってね
そこを思考を止める瞑想をしたら
思考あるから生命がいるでしょうに
そこでこれ 捨の禅定でもありながら悟りの禅定でもあります
ヤターピ パッバトーセーロー アチャロー スッパティッティトー エワン モッカ モッカ モーハッカヤー ビックー パッバトーワ ナヴェーダティ
ヤターピ パッバトーセーロー
石の山 石だけ すごい山がある
それだったらアチャロー
微妙にも動かないんですよ
山崩れするだから石じゃないからでしょ？土だからでしょ
例えばでっかい山が石だけであっちゃうと地震が起きても動かないんです
地震で地震ぐらいだったらちょっと揺れるかもしれませんだけど
例えばちゃんとあれ間にあっても
何て言いますか 地震が起こる
いろいろありますね プレートのつなげるところ
あれ？何て言います  断層ですか
断層 断層の上って言っても
でっかい山だったら全然関係ないんです
まあそれぐらいのあちゃらをつっぱってて動かないでしっかりしていますね
ええわんもうはったやびくこのように無知をなくした比丘がパッバトウは狙い出て山のように動揺しないと例えに出した
先生の訳 岩山がよく安定しているいて不動であるように
修行僧は名  名もうですか
名もうを滅ぼし尽くしているから
この  おのわない  おのわない
山岳のように  山岳のように
なんかこのプログラムになんか変なものが入っちゃって
次 自分を導く教え 次の偈でこの自分自身がテキストにした教えは何なのかと
当時でテキストはなかったんですよ
ブッダの言葉っていうのは
一つ一つキーワードでこの悟りに導くんですよ
だから自分の性格にぴったしはめるブッダの言葉が心に入っちゃうと
それと一緒に生活すると
それやってみようとすると
その人が解脱に達するんです
だから だからブッダの時代では誰だって悟ったんですね
お釈迦様教えるんだから
お釈迦様はそれぞれの人に適したキーワードを教えるんです
その人が悟るんです それでこのレイアタ長老が使ったキーワードの教えは何ですかと
アナンガナッサポーサッサニッチャンシュチガウェーシノワラッガマッタンパッパッサアッバマッターアッバマッタンバカーヤティ
これは普通お釈迦様の偈なんですね
汚点がなく 常に清きを求めている人には
毛の先ほどの悪でも  すみません
これ誤字ですね まるでですね
まるで雲のように見える
で これ私が訳したらもっと意味がいいと思いますけどね
で 清らかな人 アナンガナっていうのは
まあ直訳すれば汚点なくなんですけどね
汚点がない人が清らかな人がニッチャンシュチガウェーシノ
いつでも清浄を求めているんですね
もともと清らかですけど
清らかになりたいと思っている
その生き方をしている人が
この毛の上に何か毛の上に何も埃はあまり留まりませんね
毛の上 何かホコリがと思ったら
それでもそばのよう見える
あ 大変だ 汚れたと 心にそれぐらい微妙な汚れも入れない
入れてはいけないと お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは自分のキーワードにして修行するんです
そこを心に入っていると
毛の上にやるホコリというぐらいでも妄想はダメやと夢中で結構怖くなって頑張りますよ
ナガランヤターパッチャンタングッタンサンテラバヒラン
エワンゴーペーテアッターナンカノーホーマウパッジャガー
これブッダの言葉です
辺境にでしたっけ  辺境です
辺境にある城壁に囲まれた都市が内も外も守られているように
そのように自己を守れ
瞬時も瞬時も空しく過ごすな
違うね 意味は あの辺境に例えば町がある
危ないんですよ 町があるっていうのは
王様がいて ここはそういう感じの町なんですね
ながらといえば 誰か王みたいな人がいる
それでその人がもうしっかり外から誰も入らないようにしっかり城壁を作って
作って安全어를確保する
それだけじゃ足りません
周りもずっとそうやって警備をつけちゃって
見張りを入れて みんなもうもう遠くからでも誰か来るともう知っている
だから城壁の中にじっともう寝泊まりしていると
外から来て城壁破る可能性ありますね
そばに来るまで知らないんだけど
そうじゃない もう壊れない城壁を作ってるんだけど
かなり何キロ先までももう見張りがいるんです
だからまあ四キロ 六キロ
七キロ遠くででも誰か誰が気配を見られると
もう誰か来るんだとかね
そちらに行って先に攻撃することもできます
そのように 自分を守りなさいと
自分を守るというのは
心に悪が入らないように守って
悪は敵 だからまず自己妄想してはいけないというのは
これ中から生まれる的な
いわゆる内戦ですね テロ行為なんですね
シビルウォーになっちゃうんです
おっかない どうしようもないんですよ
例えばシリアとかはね
今シリア国民がなんとか大統領に対して戦っている
大統領は戦争だったらもう爆弾を落としちゃって
撃ちまくっちゃって勝てばいいでしょうに
そうするとアメリカが文句言う
人殺す権利はアメリカにしかありませんと
で 自分の国民を殺してどうするのか
だからそうやって内戦を打ち合うとかなりきついんですよ
外から敵が入ると なんの躊躇もなく言って潰すことできます
だから我々の心の場合は
心の中から思考 妄想が現れて
貪瞋痴が現れて自己破壊するんですね
一番怖い 敵なんですね
それはもう気づきの実践で内戦をなくさなくちゃいけない
外から敵っていうのは
近隣出身に色相 民族を振るということなんですね
そんなに難しくない 見えたものを見て欲が出てくると
あ やっぱりまずいな これは欲が生まれないようにしましょうと管理することはできます
人に言葉言われちゃって
ガクンと落っこっちゃったら
あ これ言葉は言葉にして怒らないようにしましょうとかね
そこはそんなに難しくない
比較すると内から心が生まれることが
怒りが生まれることがとても危険なんですね
そうやって外から内から自分を守りなさいと
エワンゴーペータッターナンカノーウォーマウパッジャガ
これはこの瞬間の空しく過ごすなということのいい意味ですが
この瞬間を見失うなよと
実際生きるのは瞬間 瞬間
瞬間 瞬間生きている あの瞬間で貪瞋痴やら無明やら何でもかんでもあの瞬間で起こるんです
だから瞬間で気づきがなかったらもう
失敗しちゃったんですね
寝ちゃったんですね あの瞬間で
それで煩悩的に攻撃的な攻撃を受けることになるんですね
で そういうふうな解説もできる
逆に仏教 宗教的な解説もあります
なかなか人間に生まれませんよと
もしかすると この宇宙がある場合は
我々にとってはこれ一回だけかも
また人間に生まれないかもわからない
人間に生まれたっても
知識があって 仏に出会うことは知識あることはまたあります
仏に出会うことは最も珍しいんですね
この瞬間を失うなよと
またビッグバンが万個起こる
起こるまで待たなくちゃいけないはめになります
だからこの瞬間を大事にするとか
そういうふうに仏教の世界でいろんなレベルで理解するんです
中野先生の役が一つの意味なんです
生きがいがないのは生きがい
なんか変な文章ですね
しかし それがすごい意味のある文章なんです
生きがいは全くない それが生きがいなんです
すごい元気なんです そこそこに生きがいがあると束縛されるんですね
それから抜けられませんだからね
子供が生きがいとか 仕事が生きがいと言っちゃうと
それで鎖で繋いでいますよ
だから誰かに飼われてない
犬みたいに野良犬が鳴いてるでしょ
犬っていうのは誰かに飼われて欲しいでしょ
生きがいがない人間が私
何の生き甲斐もないっていうのは
私を誰も飼ってないやって意味なんです
だから子供が生きがいというならば
自分も子供に飼われているんです
子供が自分を飼っているんです
だから自分が子供の奴隷で
それもやっている それが生きがいなんですね
人間にそういうふうに生きがいあるんだけど
あれがもうただ何に誰の奴隷になっているのかって話でしょう
じゃあ生きがいないことが生きがいなんです
本当は ナビナンダーミマラナンナービナンダーミジービタンカーランチャパティカンカーミーニッビサンバタコーヤター
誰に訳先にしますか？じゃあ先生
我は死を喜ばず このヘラジ長老を言うんですね
私は死を喜んで ああ 死にたいや
そんな失敗者じゃありません
まあ嫌になっちゃった
死んでしまいたいと それはない
次 我は生を喜ばず ああ生きていきたい
元気で こんなアホじゃないんだ
生きていきたいと 何かやり残ったこととか
もうやってやりたがっているものとか
それはない だからそこなんですね
大事なのは 次は  雇われ
雇われた人が賃金をもらうのを待つように
私は死の時が来るのを待つ
いい例えなんです だから雇われたというのは
バイトやってね 何か仕事をして
で じゃあ賃金今日ですよ
給料日ですよとね バイトだったら現金でもらったりするんだからね
すごい喜んで待ってるんですね
賃金もらう時は そのようにこの尊者が死が来るまで喜んで待ってるんです
いわゆる仕事をして終わってるんですね
だから仕事をしている
だから雇われた人が賃金払いなさいよと
賃金というのは死なんですね
体壊れるまで元気でいるんです
まずやること何もないし
責任感とかなんともないんですね
すごい解放感でいる だから生き甲斐ないことが恐ろしい生き甲斐になるんです
すごい元気で明るく明るく
死を待っているんです
ナビナンダミマラナングナビナンダミジイビタンカーランチャパティカンカーミサンパジャノーパティッシトー
我は死を喜ばす 我は生を喜ばす
よく気をつけて心掛けながら
死の時が来るのを待つ
だから聖者がやるべきことをやり終えたんだから
普通にご飯を食べてやることやって
説法をして弟子たちがいるならば教えてあげているんだよ
何か待ってるんですね
何が待ってるかというと
やっぱり体が壊れるまでいるだけなんですね
カーランチャパティカンカーミI am waiting という意味なんですね
死を喜ばずっていうのとの違いは何なんですか？ これはだから人生失敗した連中は死を喜ぶでしょ
欲がありすぎちゃって頑張ったんだけど
うまくいかない じゃあ死んでやるぞと
例えば誰かの女の人にものすごい激しく
もう愛情をすごく持っちゃって
そのあなたのことを気持ち悪いと言われたら
まあ嫌だと 自分の欲はあることですね
自殺しちゃうんです その場合は死を喜んでるんだからね
それじゃないんだよと
ただ Just waiting
だから子供たちとかなんとか
なんとかからくりやってじーっと待ってるでしょ？どうなってるのかとかね
いろいろからくりやったり
いろんなことをやって
それで座り込んでじっと待っている
それ楽しく待っているんですね
終わったと思いますけど
修行の完了ですね だから修行は完了しているんですよ
アリチンノーマヤサッタクアタンブッダッササーサナノーヒトーガルコーバーローバーウェバヴァネッティサモーハター
アリチンノーマヤサッタ
師匠がね 言った宿題は全部完成している
カタンブッダッササーサナ
ブッダの教えを実践して終わってますよ
いわゆる卒業していますと
オーヒトーガルコーバーロー
思い荷を下ろしてるんだと
ヘンリーテンショーでの思い荷なんですね
我々にとっては肉体を維持しなくちゃいけない
すごい重いんですね それから感覚を維持しなくちゃいけない
あれやこれやと五蘊を背負ってるんですね
思い荷なんです それを下ろしちゃったんです
バヴァネッティサモーハタワーシュクジャコキミ
私は死に誓えた ブッダの教えを成し遂げた
思い荷を下ろされ 下ろされた
迷いの生存に導くものはね
細きにされた なーんか分からないんですね
私は 迷いの生存に導くものは
先生もすごい頑張ってはいることはよく分かりますけどもね
私には脳細胞の中身読めるんだから
どういうふうにそこで
頑張ったかなとかね と感じますけど
場がねってっていうのは
このここで死んで終わっちゃえばいいでしょう
はい さようなら しかし
私たちはこの死にたくないんですね
だから次々次やって今もやってるんです
不安とか不満や何とかしようなんとかしよう
何とかしようとかね いつでも我々を何かあのエネルギーで生き
生きなさい 生きない 生きろ
生きろ 生きろと批判されているんですね
だから何かしなくちゃいけない
例えば どこかすごい不安定なところで立っていたら
体がグッタリするとすぐ手が行って何か捕まっちゃうんですね
その働きなんですね 例えば何か棒の上に立ちましたと
もう立てませんね まあ体揺らいでちゃって
ドキャンと倒れる 倒れたら頭でも打っちゃったら大変ですね
だから考えてない 瞬時に手を伸ばして何か捕まっていた
それが場にねってというんです
存在のコネクター コネクション
次にそこいつでもあるんですね
ねってっていうのは導く
リードする 例えば羊とかね
飼っていると 夜どこかに入れなくちゃいかんでしょう
だからこの映画とか見ているでしょ
まあ終わり乗ってまあ羊たちをね
あの なんとか犬もいますからね
あの犬もいて 犬はもうあちこち行けないように
ちゃんとあの羊たちをガードして
どんどんどんどんどん夜泊まるところに導いちゃうんですね
羊たちは何のことなく
その通りに進むんです
だから我々はね 階段を降りると考えないでも手すりを取っているでしょうに
何か立っているところはギリってやっちゃうと
もう何か捕まってるでしょうに
それが場ね っていうなんで
ここ地震が起きたら皆さんよく皆さんに分かりますよ
地震来たら私は全く微塵も動揺しない
そんなのはいるんですけど
皆なっちゃうんですね
だからこの しかし私は階段下りるところはちゃんと捕まりま
す あれは痛いんだからね
もう今お膝が痛くてね
階段下りることできますが
上ることできない できない
いくらなんでも痛いのは嫌です
はい そこでこのバヴァネッティって専門用語で
存在のコネクターなんですね
電気コードがある  1メートル
もう元足らない あっともう 1メートルあればと
例えば 2メートルのものを買っちゃえば話は終わりですけど
例えば 1メートルある
もう 1個  1メートルの電気コードがある
どうする？つなげるでしょ
とても簡単に  2メートルの電気コードが 2つあった
1メートルの電気コードが 2つあったら
それ 2メートルとして使える
だって売ってる電気コードでは壁のあれに
アウトレットに 英語でアウトレットというんですね
日本語でコンセントでしたっけ
アウトレットに挿すあれあるでしょ
それから電気出すところ
またあるでしょうに だからつなげればいいんだから
だから電気コードに過去と将来って 2つコネクタがあるんですよ
まああれはオスメスというんですけどね
そのように我々の心にもコネクタがあるんです
まあ存在欲なんですよ
だからそこは瞑想する人はよく発見して実験発見するんですよ
生きたい 生きていきたいという気持ち
見つかるんですね あ これやと
皆様はただ生きていきたいだけだけど
全然気づいてないんですよ
その代わりに怯えがある
その代わりに不安がある
あるいはものすごく欲があって物を溜める
ふんごろ貸し持ちみたいな
溜めて溜めて自慢する
こんなことじゃなくて
自分が生きていきたい
死にたくないというこれを発見してほしいんですね
そう簡単ではないんですよ
誰だって死にたくないと言っているわりに
この生きたがっているこの心のエネルギーを明確に取り出して経験していない
これ取り出して経験してみてください
それにバヴァネッティという
これがコネクターなんです
だから我々はいつでもバヴァネッティのせいでご飯を食べる
もう芸術エステランなんとか
芸術鑑賞  鑑賞する時でもあれが働かせている
音楽聴く時でも この存在をつなげるコネクターでコネクションやっている
このバヴァネッティ サマーダはもうコネクター切っちゃったんだ
もう壊しちゃったんです
だから過去にはコネクタありましたよ
過去のコネクタあって
今まで生きてきたんです
それで悟りに達した瞬間で
次のコネクションを壊しちゃったんです
ヤッサチャッハヤパッバジトゥアガースマナガーリヤン
ソーメアッボアナッパットサッバサンヨウジャナッカヨ
私は出家して家なき状態に入った
その目的を私は達成した
それはすべての束縛を滅ぼし尽くすことであった
あれも執着ですね サッバサンヨウジャ
すべての束縛をもう切断しましたと
出家した目的に達していますよ
だいたいこのアラカンは
このアラカンになったということは
このような言葉で表現します
覚えておいてください
この あの これはあの 自分が悟っているんだと自慢したい人々いるでしょ
言葉聞いただけで これは病気ですぐわかるんですよ
本物の聖者たちの言葉とちょっと違うんです
だから そういう古代妄想で悩んでいる人々は
ちょっと私の授業を受ければ
このアラカ 本物の人はどんな風に言葉を使うのかと教えてあげられますけどね
そうするといくらでも人を騙せられます
アラカンという言葉 一言も出てないでしょ
出てないんです 実際 自分が経験した世界を語っているだけです
見えなくなっちゃったこれが
わからない言葉
サンパデー タッパマーデーナ エーサーメー アヌーサーサニー ハンダーハン パーラニッビッサン ピッパムットーミ サッバディー怠ることなく
背め励めよ これが私の教え戒めである
さあ 私はまどかな安らぎに入るでしょう
であろう 私はあらゆる事柄について解脱している
だからここで解脱という仏教用語を使っても
本当は自由になっているなんですね
これ解脱という単語正しいんですよ
解脱というのは自由って意味なんです
私も自由ですよと 私は阿羅漢ですよとはないんです
作者の幽玄と同じ言葉ですね
この霊場と尊者が お釈迦様が涅槃に入られた入られる瞬間前に語った同じ言葉を語っている
だからわからないのはどちらが先ですかっていうことなんです
サーリプッタ尊者がお釈迦様より先に涅槃に入られたんだけどね
この第一聖者はどっちもわからない
とにかく悟った人にとって別れの言葉っていうのはそれしかないんです
自分が自由を得ているんです
これで最後の息を止めます
あなた方の気づきを実践しなさいよと
この怠るなくなんだらかんだりたっていても
不放逸で気づきを実践しなさい
それはあの瞬間を無駄に使うなよという意味でも同じ意味なんですね
だからエーサーメー アヌーサーサニー私にはあなた方に言い得て一言はそれだけですよ
遺言は 怠るなく 背めましょう
背め励めよ 私にはハンダーハン パーラニッビッサンまあ私はこれから涅槃に入ります
いわゆる死にますということ
じゃあこれから私は死にますからね
頑張ってください みんな
私はもうあらゆるものから自由になっています
羅刹を待っていたんだからね
はい これでわかりますかね
これ レーオ族長老が涅槃に入る瞬間で語ったこのテーラワーダの歌なんですね
だから 王様のお話もつなげているでしょうと思います
霊場尊者の歌は で これは別な解釈では霊場尊者のフェアウェルトークなんですね
この存在から輪廻からもう脱出する
みんなにフェアウェル
さよならという言葉なんですね
その中で自分がどのように修行したかと
自分の生き方はどういうふうな生き方ですかと
精神状態はどういうもの全て語られている
自分がどんなブッダの言葉をガイドラインにしていたのかとかね
全ての経典じゃないんです
あの 2つの例なんですね
だからこの省略して内容を言ったんだけど
この内容はすごい膨大なんですね
まあそこに行くしかないんですよ
またもう一人お坊さん待ってるんだろう
ゴータマ尊者のお坊たちの前ではね
仏教ではいろんなキャラがいるんですよ
だからどちらのどちらかというとわからない
どうしても仏典のエピソードっていうのは
そういうしっかりしたエピソードが書かないんですね
出来事に出来事に合わせる
合わせるんですね おそらく私の推測なんですけど
あるキャラバンで商人やってる人ですね
ゴータマの家は 昔はキャラバンですけどね
たくさんの 500台とかね
車をつなげて大量に品物
だから動くスーパーという動くデパートですね
移動デパートで商人ですね
だから移動デパートだから大変ですよ
キャラバンっていうのはね
だから自分たちの食べるものやら寝るところやら
もう全部持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
そこでこの大体最初そこら辺にもうキャラバンでね
500台くらい車 牛 馬か馬の車か分かりませんだけど
牛車か馬車かよく分からないんだけども
牛車ですね 大体馬っていうのは怠け者で荷物は危ないんですね
そこで行く途中で一つの牛がね
あまりにも疲れちゃって倒れちゃったんですね
で 前に進めなくなっちゃって
足が弱く弱くなって座り込んじゃったんですね
そこでもう立たせようと思っても立たないんですね
この牛さんは そこでこのゴータマがこの社長だからね
して もうものすごいもう鞭で打って
ものすごい侮辱しちゃったね
牛を ものすごく激怒して侮辱したら
この牛さんが突然声変えて
お前 残酷な人間だよ 血も涙もない
あまりにも残酷なけしからん人間だ
お前に罰が当たると牛が叱ったそうです
それ聞かないでください
テキストにそうありましたからね
とにかく気をつけて牛に近寄らない方がいいんですね
叱られたら大変 叱ったんですね
罰が当たる で それにゴータマさんがすごいショック受けちゃって
自分がもう自分の都合だけ見て牛 1匹座り込んでいると
それで止まらなくちゃいけないんですね
だからどうしますかね
もしかすると あとほんのちょっと行ったところでキャンプ作れるかも
だから何かあったでしょうに
でもほんの10歩先であっても牛が動かないんだから
普通だったら車から外してあげて
どうですか？お前大変疲れたでしょうとかね
体なでてあげて なんとか牛さんがやっぱり頑張ってくれるんですよ
それはしなかったんですね
だから自分の残酷さとわがままと自分の利益しか考えないことにものすごくショックを受けちゃって
そのまま出家したっていう話もあります
で それで 2番目のダイヤラカンに入りますが
ゴータマって名前でいろいろいるんですよ
もう面白いお坊さんがいて
これスリランカにいたお坊さんで注釈書に入ってるんですね
ゴータマってこのお坊さんが托鉢に出る場合は必ず午前中でしょう
自分の影が西村 西村と言うんですね
この昔 指で言うんですからね
インチですね 訳すると
あのツーインチまでになっている
まだ上に来てないんですね
その時たくわんてご飯をいただいて
1 センチの間でご飯食べて終わっちゃうんです
すごいそこら辺は変ですね
まあだからおそらく時計で言えばよくわからないんだけどね
11時でたくわんに出て
ちょうど 10時11時半でご飯食べて終わったという感じ
あるいは 11時半で出て
11時45分でたくわん終わっちゃって
残り 15 分で食べて終わったというね
時間がすごい GPS みたいな感じで厳しい
このお坊さん どれほど上手かというと
空が曇っていてもぴったし
その時間で出て ぴったりその時間に食事を取ってはいるんです
それを見て一般人が 自分たちに時間がわからなくなると
あの長老の時間に自分の時計を合わせるんだそうです
有名なゴータはスリランカにいた昔のもう一人
アビダンマのすごい専門家のゴータ
それもスリランカにいたお坊さんでね
いろんな私みたいな勝手な意見いっぱい持ってるんですね
そこで注釈書でそのゴータ長老がアビダンマゴータ長老がこう言ったいた
でもそれは見てまで全部チャラって捨てちゃうんですね
それかっこ悪いんです
その長老が自分なりに意見を持ってるんだけど
注釈書を編集するブッダ長老をはじめとした方々はこれはあげません
だから間違っていると捨てちゃうんです
自我と差別は俗世間の境地
ジャタビバッドアージャンヨドゥーレーユットドゥラーサホ
原文はドゥラサホになってますが
注釈書はドゥラーサホになってますから
私はドゥラーサホっていうことは好みです
音律が残るんですね ドゥラサホよりは
マティトアティバーレーナサンサンユガンナアティワットティ
血統の良い尊めが身を結びつけられていても
身に耐え 可動の荷物に心が乱されていても
具足を離れないように
この あの これって本当に馬ってそんなもんかよくわかりませんだけど
これ人間がね 動物にも余計なキャラをつけちゃいますからね
どうしようもない ライオンが百獣の王にしているしね
ライオンに教えてない方がいいわ
どう教えたら何するかわからないんだから
俺が王様で じゃあ頑張るわ
冗談じゃないんだけどね
そこで孔雀がものすごい傲慢であると
かわいそう そうですね
狐がいつでもずる賢くてね
悪いことばっかりしちゃうし
そういう人間っていうのは動物に色々キャラを被せるんですね
そこでこの馬っていうのは普通使う動物なんですけど
馬には一応性格はあるんですね
馬が好きな人間いるし
馬に馬が嫌う人間もいる
私は動物 私のこと動物は全然嫌うと嫌がらないんですね
しかし馬は私のこと嫌いです
私は馬のこと嫌いではないんだけどね
じゃあ見るとあんたあっち行けって
それでも触ってると噛んじゃうんです
痛いでしょうにと だからこの
何て言いますかね 動物にも色々キャラがね
かぶっちゃって この駿馬っていうのはそうやってよくわからない
私は知ったことはない
サラブレサラブレッドでしょうかね
サラブレッドってのはイギリスでできた種だからね
イギリスから輸入したわけではないしね
うーん 素晴らしい馬であると
馬の中の王様で 王様がこのサラブレッドにしか乗らないとかね
そこで鞭で打つ必要はないと
鞭を手に上げると影見えるんだそうです
影見えたらこのこの人はどんな何を期待してる？よく読んで
あ スピード下げたいみたいだって下げる
上げたいんじゃ上げると
だからこの鞭の影だけでわかるんだと
だから馬も人を選ぶということもあります
気に入らない人が乗ったらとにかく落とすという
だからその馬には荷物を運ばせませんだけどね
とにかくこれは文学表現だとしましょう
ライオンは百獣の王様と同じくね
いつどこで王になったかどうか
それは調べる必要はないでしょう
あの どんな国を支配しているのかどうか
しかし 性格のいい馬は
あの この車にくびきつけたら嫌がらないで仕事をする
あるいは荷物を入れてもう動いて動いて動いてもうクタクタ
でもまだまだ飼い主が行けというんだから行く
行けというならば あるいはもう運べないぐらい荷物を入れたっても
自分の仕事はする 文句言わない
疲れてるんだから あの
前の話の牛さんみたいに座り込む
これはありえない 与えられた仕事はやる
荷物は重いとか 今日はクタクタ疲れたとかね
今日は運びたくないとか
そこはわがまま出せない
そのような馬 エヴァンパンニャーヤテーティイエーティッタサムドゥワーリナヤタナパーレアティマーマンニャンティアリーヤダンムオパーニナ
水の待ちている海のように知恵に待ちている人々は他人を軽蔑しない
これが生きる者どもの尊い理である
アリーヤダンムは尊い生き方
生命の 生命の尊い生き方っていうのは
いかなる場合でも他を軽蔑しない
馬と同じ 言い訳は言わない
だから馬にとって荷物は重いでしょうに １
頭の馬に馬にこんなのを運べるわけない
それは言わない 自分で我慢する
で 世の中で生きている場合は
あらゆる人々に出会う
あらゆる生命に出会う
それを言い訳にして軽蔑するということは一切しない
お前なんか仕事も下手で何だこりゃと言わない
だからこの場合は単純なサービスじゃない
ものすごい尊いレベルの聖なるレベルの仏道を悟った人のゲッダチャシャの無差別
差別のない生き方なんです
だからこれ二つはものすごい重いんですよ
説明しにくい だから省略して飛ばすしかないんです
差別について言っても
私がもう一時間くらい喋る内容データがあるんです
だから私たちは他を差別する
まず区別する 区別は仕方がないことにしても
区別の次差別になるんですね
いわゆる区別に判断を入れる
良し悪しの それが差別です
例えばこの人は男 この人は女
これは区別です これは仕方がない
男の方がいい もう差別
女の方がいい 差別 まあこの仕事はやっぱり女の方がよろしいというね
これは差別じゃない それは区別
ある仕事があって 男にもできる
女にもできる しかしこれ人間関係のことだから
人々のわがままを聞かなくちゃあかんだから
やっぱり女の方がその場合はいいんじゃないと決まるのはいいんですよ
こんなの女の仕事だって言ったら
これが差別です じゃあお茶入れるの誰が入るの？そんなの女に決まってるでしょ
あれは恐ろしい差別なんです
お茶入れるのは上司にお茶入れる人の仕事なんです
料理するのは料理上手な人の仕事なんです
それが区別の能力が必要です
だから皆さんわかる どれぐらい皆様ご自分で一日中どれぐらい差別しているのかと
差別は罪ですよ 悪行為なんです
冗談じゃないんです 軽々くやってはいけません
よくよく調べた方がよろしいんですね
区別は仕方がないんですね
区別でそれより差別もするぞと
なんだこりゃと だから駿馬っていうのはなかなか駿馬って読むんですか？ 駿馬で大丈夫です
駿馬 まあ本当にいるのかいという疑問に思うような馬なんですね
駿馬の性格をテキストで読んでみると
そんな馬がいるのかいと私は疑問にしますが
白い象も本当にいるのかと問われたら
やっぱりいるんですよ
大量にタイにいるんですね
で タイの王様が死んじゃったんだからね
だからまた一年間 やってますからね
回しちゃえばいいのに
そんなこと言いたいよ
そちらにこの一般人に今まで一度も見せなかった白い象たち のパレードをやって
あの連中に訓練させてパレードやって
王様にも礼をする 亡くなった方に
だから白いのは白かったんだけど
仕事をさせてない象たちだから
あまりかっこよくなかったんですよ
体がでっかいんだけど
あの象たちが仕事するでしょ
そうするとなんかスマートになるんですよ
まあそれで でも象がいるかどうか私はわかりません
白い象がいることははっきりわかります
そこで この聖者の場合は知恵に心が満たしちゃうんですね
海のように 海にとっては差別する必要はないんですね
誰も それが聖なる教えで
仏道の教えであると はい
次に行きます 有無の罠
あ これあの ちょっと理解してください
霊芝長老とこの長老の性格随分違うでしょ
霊芝長老が慈悲喜捨のプロなんです
しかし どうだったでしたっけ？長老も生命としては態度持ってます
どういう態度かというと
微妙にでも差別しない
だから慈悲喜捨となんか違うね
そこで有無の罠 カーレカーラワサンパッターバババワサンガタナラドッカニガッチャンティテータソーチャンティマナワ
若き人々は時間のうちにあって時間に支配され
死生の迷いの存在に赴き
苦しみを受けて この世で悲しむ
仏教の基本的な教えは認めませんという態度で日本訳すると
本当にもう難しいんですよ
では 私の訳します カーレカーラワサンパッターカーレ出たっけ？あ
出てます カーレ 時間とは現象の生滅流れです
時間っていうのはないんです
人間が頭で考えたものなんです
だから時間を考えるために人間に役に立ったのはものの変化なんです
最初の時間っていうのは昼と夜でしょう
人間作った だから神に時間あることおかしい
神は七日間で世界を創ったでしょうね
昼を作って夜を作って
それで七日でふたご作られちゃったと
仕事をしろよ だから疲れるでしょ
で だからおかしいんですね
まあそれはとにかく物事は変化する
昼があって夜があるという変化でしょうに
それ時間ありだったんです
ほぼ夜と昼が均等だから
ほぼ均等だからね とにかく分けて
そこはもう切って切って考えましょうと
だから昔の日本の時間っていうのは二十四時間じゃないでしょ
昔何時間でした？一日何時間？六時間とかなんとか
で インドでは一日どれぐらい時間だと思う？六十時間です
シックスティアワーズアデイ
トゥエンティフォーアワーズじゃないんです
だから昼三十時間で夜三十時間
そこで一時間はシックスティミニッツシックスティセカンズという風に
それを分けてます これ性質はしっかりしています
だけどまあ計算昔からやっていたんだからね
だから二十四時間よりは六十時間の方がもっとまとめでしょうに
だって全部シックスティシックスティシックスティだから
計算すると面倒くさいんですよ
私はもっと怠け者だから重々重りするんですね
で まあそこはちょっと精密じゃない考えですけど
だから一秒はインドの一秒は西洋の一秒より短い
あの二秒半です インドの二秒半は西洋の秒です
そういうことで それでわかるでしょ
日本では古い時計ではまあなんか時間十二時ではないんですね
博物館で見たんだからね
だから自分好きなように時間作ればいいんです
しかし 誰でも日夜のことは取り消せませんね
地球にいるんだから だから時間とは変化に時間を作るために変化が必要なんです
そこで生命体の面白いことは
時間がないのに時間にやられているんです
時間に支配されている
それで皆様もそう思ってるでしょ
時間に追われているんだと
それは大したことないんです
本当の時間に支配されているということはそうじゃないんです
時間とは色声想行識でしょう
時間とはこの現象の世界でしょう
これ変化しているでしょう
支配されています ものすごい難しい例を出します
洗濯物を干す 干したら雨が降り出す
どうする？テレビ見るね
終わり 支配されているでしょ
時間に どうしようもないんですよ
冬になってくると冬の準備する
春になってくると春の準備をする
今私にはちらちらと太鼓の音を聞こえてきますね
今夏になるんだから あれやらなくちゃかんだからね
なんとかありますからね
どっちゃんサービスのお祭り
今日聞こえた音っていうのはあまりもしっかりしてる
もしかすると太鼓なんか外出したばっかしかも
一円もね 買っておいてまだ調整してない
だからちょうどその時間になってくるとみんな動くんです
桜が花が咲くとみんな頭狂っちゃうんです
仕方がないんです もう時間に支配され
出てるんです そのうち桜見ますよと
できませんよ 桜見たければそのうちではないんです
咲いている時やらなくちゃいけないんです
だから無常の世界 それは時間の世界
無常の世界 時間の世界にべったしはめている人々は
時間の 言うままに動かなくちゃいけないんです
例えば我々年取るでしょ
時間ですよ それも年取ったとは物質が衰えたっていうことでしょう
物質が衰えてないんだけど
衰えませんだからね まあ変化するだけで物質ではなくて
細胞組織が組織として衰えたんです
体にある水が衰えたわけじゃないんです
体にある炭素が衰えたわけじゃないんです
細胞組織として衰えた
そうすると我々はそれに合わせるんです
若者をはさむのも時間に支配されています
青年たちが大胆なことをやったり
もうみんなもう困っちゃったなとか思わせるのも時間ですよ
時間に支配されているんです
カーラヴァサン 存在は生滅流れに流されているんですね
流されています 年取る流れはどうにもならんでしょ
どうにもならん 子供の時は遊ぶんですよ
真剣 真面目に勉強します
そんなのはわからないんです
じゃあ二人で経済学でも喋りましょうと
ありえないんですね 歳がね
バヴァーバヴァサンガタ
これは本当は有無の罠にはめられているということなんです
それは中尾先生はごまかしてますね
迷いの存在に赴きというね
種々の バヴァーっていうのは存在
アバヴァーっていうのは非存在ですね
やっぱり有無なんで生と死なんですね
物事は生まれては消える
どちらにしたっても支配されている
新たなこと生まれると
我々はそれに従わなくちゃいけない
何かが消えてくる 来ると
それに従わなくちゃいけない
わかりやすい例 新しい命が生まれると
我々はそれに合わせてお誕生日おめでとうございますやら
あれやこれやとか持っていくお土産も決まっていてね
あの まあ何と言いますか
御三卿 そうやってこの子供が生まれたら
皆様あのでっかい一升瓶とか送る
お祝いとして あるいはすごい腕のいいケーキ屋さんのでっかいケーキでも送る？送らないでしょ
子供を産んだらそちらにあげるものは決まっている
誰が決まったんですかね
誰でもない この無常の流れがそこを指令しているんです
それで子供が生まれる時でしょ
新たな仕事が生まれるんです
生まれたっていう そこで死ぬでしょ
死んだ瞬間どうなる？新たな仕事が生まれるんです
だから有であろうか 無であろうか
結局は面倒くさいんです
親が衰えて病気でいるとすごい仕事忙しいんです
病気ですから そこを死んじゃったら楽ちんでしょうに
面倒見なくてもいいし
お風呂に入れてあげなくてもいいし
車椅子で散歩させなくてもよろしいし
トイレの世話しなくてもいいでしょ
楽ちん 楽ちんところじゃない
亡くなったらそれから
まあ葬式やら法要って
あれやこれやと現れてくる
財産あるならば財産どうするのか
この人は会社持っていたならば
じゃあ会社これからどうするのかと
いろんなものを生まれたんですよ
だから我々は鬼やられていて
もにやられているんです
もう逃げられませんね
子供が元気でいる場合も面倒くさいし
病気になって寝込んじゃったらまた面倒くさいんですね
何かやらなくちゃ そのようにババビババの
あるいはババアババ そちらにやられているんです
生命が だからいつでも苦しみ味わっているんです
テーダソーチャンティマーナ
だから人間それによって悩んでるんです
子供が生まれても悩む
人が死んでも悩む羽目になってるんです
どちらにしても悩む種が現れてるんです
子供が生まれたらおめでたい？おめでたいじゃない
どうしようどうしようとかね
歯がちゃんと時期に出てくるかとかね
ちゃんと時期に言葉喋れなかったらすごい悩むでしょ？時々子供は喋るの遅い子供たちいるでしょ？足すの遅い子供たちがいるでしょ？相当悩むんですよ
子供が元気なんですけど
喋れない お医者に見せるんですよ
すごく心配するんですね
もしもし喋れないとは
もし全く音を聞いてないかもね
それで音を聞こえる 大丈夫です
健康ならそのうち喋りますよ
医者が言うんだけど 親にとっては
はぁ悩みの種 だから子供がどうなって元気であっても悩みの種
病気であっても悩みの種
学校どうしましょう 教育どうしましょうとかね
だからそういう風にこの現象にある現象にはめられている生命には悩みから抜けられません
これをオウムの罠と私は省略したんです
そこら辺は中村先生が理解してるんです
先生らしいこと言って大変バチが当たりますからね
まあこれは仕方がないんですね
学者としてはね 空楽中のつなぎを切る
この空楽中というのは空楽不空
不空と だから中と入れたんで面倒くさいんだから
うん ウッナター スカダンメーナ ドゥッカダンメーナ チョーナター ドゥエーナ バアラハンニャンティ ヤター ブータン アダッシーノ
はい 楽しい事柄にうきうきして昂ぶり
苦しい事柄にがっかりして沈み愚痴んどもはこの両者に悩まされする事柄をあるがままに見ないように
すごい苦労してます 役人はね
はい これ私だったらね
物事をありのままに見ないんだから
無知な人をね 楽になったらもう何て言いますか
高ぶりね 苦しくなっちゃうと落ち込んでそれだけでは良くないんです
だから楽しくなっても愚か者は苦しむんです
苦しくなっても愚か者は苦しむんです
ハンニャンテっていう言葉は
だからあの日本語でなんか同じ単語を使っているような感じのパーリ語でそうじゃないんですね
悩み 楽しくなったら悩む
苦しくなったら悩む どちらでも悩みの種になるんです
イエーチャドゥッケースカマースカスミンチャマッジェーチャシッベリマッジャゴーティターテーインダキーローワナテーウンナタオーナター
これ本当は私の注入れた方がいいんだけど
入れてなかったっけ えーと
楽のうちにありながらも
妄執を超えている人々は入り口の
石の如く  石の如くに安住して
安定している  安定している
彼らはウキウキして高ぶることもなく
がっかりして沈むこともない
これはおそらく伝統的にイギリス人が英訳してからずっとこの意味で言ってるとは思います
おそらく注釈書は調べてないんだけど
注釈書もそのような意味で解説しているとは思います
でも私は自分の 何と言いますか
わがままな解説をします
ドッカ苦しみ スッカ楽しみですね
マッジェー その間 注 間でシッベリマッジャが
このシッベリっていうのは
あの 縫う仕事をつなぐんですね
それは正常はやりません
苦しくなると我々は必ず何をする？必ず苦しみをなくして楽を目指すんです
つなげるんです 楽になると
あ この調子でどうすればこの維持できるかと
繋ぐことばっかり考えるんです
このシッベリっていうのは
ブッダがこの葛藤に使う
あの 縫う仕事をする針
お針子  お針子っていう意味なんです
だから布二つあったらバラバラで針が間に行ってしまっちゃえば一枚になっちゃうんです
このカッスワエなどというこの針を針ではなくて
この針で言った あの糸
だから過去現在未来と生老病死というそういうことでしょう
命がつながるんですね
何で繋がったかというと
過去は過去で関係ない
将来は将来 例えば我々の若頃っていうのは
今から見るとまるっきり別人でしょ
物質的にも思考も性格も自分じゃないでしょ
過去は過ぎ去った 関係ない
将来もわからない もう関係ない
しかし 私たちは過去と今と将来を
あの お針子でお針子さん
あの つなげておくんです
だからお針子さんが自分なんです
自分自身の心のカスアイなんです
だからまるっきり別人でである過去の生活ぶりに
私の子供頃のことやと言うんです
そこでカスワエやら煩悩やら何でもかんでも生まれる
すいません それそのお針子さんっていうのは
さっきのレワタ長老が言っていたマバネッティっていうのと同じような
うん 同じです 聖者はインダキーラっていうのは
この建物を作る場合は
まず昔の建物はよくわかりませんだけど
ものすごい安定した柱を作るんですね
柱を支えて家を作る 屋根を作るんですね
とにかく微量にも動かない
安定した柱を意味するインダキーラっていう時に
大黒柱ですか  大黒 まあそう
まあわからない 日本の五重塔の場合は
この柱が必要なんです
ちょっと見学に行ったら見て中に入ってみてください
下から上まで一本の柱があるんです
あれはまず作るんです
すっごい安定して作るんです
それから五重の屋根をつなげてつなげてつなげていくんです
京都とかね いろんなところ
日本にあるでしょうね
あの屋根が五枚重ねてるね
建物 あの建物の場合はインダキーラがどうしても使っていたんです
現代技術使っちゃもう柱なく作れますよ
鉄があるし まあもう木でもね
使えますよ 別にマイクロ木
穴をいろいろありますけどね
もう木の仕事は昔にするともっと良かったですけどね
あれ 釘も使ってないんだからね
つなげるだけですよ だからそれは相当な仕事なんです
で とにかくそういう安定しているものですね
だからこの今の瞬間だけできてるんだから揺らぎがないんですね
つなげてない 過去と将来に
功楽につなげてないんです
張り仕事やってないんです
蓮の葉に乗った水滴 ナヘーラーラーベーナラーラーベーナラセーナチャッきっといや
ナニンナニンディーナニンダーヤンパサンサーヤナテードゥッケーツカンミー
実に利益にも損失にも
名声にも 名誉にも 非難にも
賞賛にも 苦しみにも 楽しみにも
サッバタテーナリンカンテウデビップウポッカレーサッバタスキターディーラサッバタプラジター
彼らはいかなることにも汚されない
蓮華の上の水滴のように
たけき人は あらゆる事柄について
楽しく あらゆる事柄について
うーん  破れることはない
破れることはない まあこれぐらいの
全てストーリーで説法されていますよ
この長老が で 苦楽やらいろんなものに人がもう揺らぐ
揺らぐ 揺らぐ 繋ぐんですね
みんな 繋ぎを切っちゃったらもう大黒柱のようにじっといられますよと
そこで あの 世の中の流れっていう風に
仏教でお釈迦様がこの八つの項目を教えてますね
損得 名誉不明誉 賞賛非難
苦楽というね 八つありますね
これは生命に対してはもうこれは回転します
そこで自我がある生命が苦に出会うと落ち込む
楽になってくるともう浮き
舞い上がっちゃうとかね
だから何なのかと もう心の安らぎはないんです
だってこの八つの回転ずっと来てるんだから
だからずっと心が悩みっぱなしで
だからやり方はね この
放っておくと私がよく使っている単語なんですけど
そのまま放っておけと
で 繋げないことなんですね
例えば子供が昨日すごく元気で遊んでいた
今日は遊ばない どこかに座っていると
でお母さんが昨日と今日繋げるでしょ
繋げた瞬間でもう心が動揺するんです
お母さんたちが面白くて
将来にも将来十年 二十年
八十年まで繋げるんです
だからもう耐えられないぐらい心配してるんですけど
まあ無知だから全然感じてないんですけど
例えば若者がもう仕事も頼んだこともやらないで
もう遊んでいる そこを将来まで繋げてみてください
大変なことになります
こんなことをやったらあんたどうなるのかと
あんたこれ真面目に仕事する気持ちがなくなるでしょうと
あんた何でもふざける人間になるんだよと
あんた仕事行って一日で首追い出されるかもしれません
そうするとホームレスになるかもしれません
親が死んじゃったらどうするのかと
いくらでも将来に繋げてみると
悩むことはいくらでもできる
同じく過去に繋いでみるといくらでも悩みます
そういう風にこの阿羅漢たちの精神を語る場合は
ちょっと難しいことを言わなくちゃあかんです
もう軽々しく喋れないんです
あの聖者たちの超一流の哲学者たちなんです
実践哲学者たちなんです
だからこの長老が前の長老と違って別な人格ですけど
同じ真理を別な角度で語られているんですね
だからサッバタッパラジタ
どこでも負けませんよ
繋げない人は あの例えだったのはこの蓮の水滴なんですけど
本当はこの蓮の葉の上にある水滴のように
この苦楽損得などなどには関係ない
蓮の葉はラブラブ 損得
名誉不明誉 賞賛非難 楽苦なんですね
その八つ それは蓮の葉の上にどうにかといっても
その上に一滴の水のようにいるんだよと
美しく輝いて で これからまた人格が見えてきます
違法の得より合法の損は優れている
皆様怒るかもしれませんだけど
ダンメイナチャアラボヨヨチャラボアダンミク
アラボダンミクセイヨヤンチェラボアダンミク
正しい方法による損失もあり
不正な方法により利得もある
不正な方法による利得よりも
正しい方法による損失の方が優れている
全然美しくない文章 [笑い]いわゆる行儀よく道徳を守って
素直に真面目にやって損しましたと
あるいはからくりやって
ごまかしやって 違法なことをやって得しました
そういう二つ世の中にあります
その中で損した方が勝ちやと
道徳を守って合法的にやったことで
あなたは損しましたら素晴らしいやと
こういうすごい哲学なんですね
世の中にない哲学なんです
例えば ある人がすごく素直で
すごく正直で すごく真面目で
すごく道徳を守って生きてみる
そうするとみんなにけなされるわ
騙されるわ 例えば八時間仕事をしたのに六時間の給料しかくれないわ
いろいろやられるかもしれません
雇った人は まあこいつはもう大丈夫
いくらでも言うとるから金ごまかせると
労働なんたらかんたら基準で訴えてこないように
わかったらやりたい放題
だからこの合法的に生きて損したっても
それがすごい立派なことだと
違法に得するよりは ヤソウチャアッアブッディーナンウィンニューナンアエソ
アエソセイヨウィンニューナンナヤソウアッパブッディーナン
えーと 英知の少ない人々が名声を得ることもあり
聡明な人々が不名誉を受けることもある
聡明な人々が受ける不名誉の誉が
あ すみません 誉がですね
誉が 英知の少ない人々の得る名声よりも優れている
まあわかりやすく言うならば
このアホなんですけど
世の中にすごい褒められている
本当に理性のある立派な人です
みんな非難する これよくあること
世の中でしっかり物事を言う
役目と言う人は馬鹿にする
人の機嫌を取って踊ってる人はもういい人ですよとかね
言われるんですよ ですから
知識人の聡明な人が非難されることは
それは素晴らしいことです
非難されたからといってどうしたことない
あんたは素晴らしい方です
だから世の中だいたいこの人気出てくると
みんながそろってくると
他の私もあの人のやり方を真似ましょうとかね
私は宗教の世界 人間だから
宗教の世界で このたくさん信者さんを獲得するために
たくさんのお布施をもらうために
たくさんのすごいからくり
悪いこと いろんなことをやっちゃうんですね
ご利益を売ったり 色々お守りを売ったり
あれやこれやとかね とにかく
賢者でいて 理性のある人でいて
非難を受けてもいいんです
例えば仏教に入れましょうか
無常の話やら無執着の話やら
もう金儲かりばっかしやってるあなた方は奴隷やというふうな話で
社会が嫌な気持ちになるでしょう
そんな話する社会に非難を受けるでしょう
構いません と 事実を言いなさい
なんです だから 若い二人が結婚しようと思っちゃうと
私はね あなた方は今日からね
ものすごい苦しい世界に入りますよと
お互いにストレス溜まって自由がなくて
束縛されて まあどうしようもない世界にこれから入りますよ
頑張ってくださいと言っちゃうと
なんだこの坊主は おめでとう
おめでとうございます
どうか長生きしますように
どうかもう幸福な そういうべきではないか
本当はそうじゃないんです
お前はどう見ても馬鹿にしか見えませんだから結婚しなさい
馬鹿で なんで馬鹿？馬鹿だから結婚してそれで大丈夫？いえ
それだったら馬鹿が受けることで喧嘩するわね
いろいろ失敗するわ 互いにものわかりになるわとかね
いろんなことありますよと
それは馬鹿馬鹿の運命的なことだからね
じゃあやってみなさいと
他は何かあるか？問題は何もない
だから本当のことをやっぱりこの世の中
世の中で言えないということもあるんですよ
この長老言うのはその道が正しいんだと
賢者の非難 恩利の苦が優れている
また言うんですね まあ私の意味で言います
あの お墓からすごく褒めることもありますよと
賢者から馬鹿にされるんだ
それが世の中によくなります
あんた素晴らしいとやって私に言われたら
とんでもないアホなんですね
アホにあんた本当に性格悪いね
怠け者だな 怠け者でしょと言われると
それですごい立派な人格者なんですね
それで私は立派な人格者に馬鹿にされることをありがたいと思わなくちゃいけないんです
この普通の一般人に褒められて褒められて
もうあなた見ただけでも心が慰められますよと
あんなものはすごいお仏のように敬慕した方がいいんです
これだけ意味なんです
スカンチャカーママイカン
カーママイカン ドゥッカーンチャパヴィリーティヤン
パヴィレーカドゥッカーンセーヨ
ヤンチエーカーママヤンスカン
欲望の快楽から起こる快感もあり
なんたらかんたら 欲望で快楽ありますよと
そこで欲望から離れようと思っちゃうと苦しくてしょうがない
時間ですね  時間ですね
はい 早く終わります えーと
欲望から離れた苦しみはあります
でも 欲から離れた苦しみが素晴らしいと
飛ばさなければじゃなくなりました
不法の生より合法の死が選ぶ
これは一つの修行をした上で素晴らしいこと
ものすごい大胆に語ってますよ
この長老が 悪いことをして生きるよりは
正しいことをして死んだ方がマシだと
その話です 次の偈に来ます
カーマコーパパヒーナージャ イーサンタ キッタ ババダヴェ チャランティ ローキケ アシタ ナティ デサン ピヤピアン
快楽も怒りも捨て去って
死生の生存のうちにあっても心沈まり
執着することなく 世の中を歩む人々
彼らには解も不解も存在しない
まあ阿羅漢にとっては解不解って関係ないんですよ
またありますよ 次の偈
バラヴェーットワナ ボージャンゲ インディヤニ バラーナチャ
だから聖者がこの自分のことを言ってますよ
自分がこの七覚支をね
修行しましたと 五力五根を修行しましたと
最上の力で はいはい それで
すごい哲学者なんですね
で はい そういうことで
生死の関係ない乗り越えてあったという長老二人ののお話でした
ありがとうございます
ちょっと聞きたいことがあるんですけど
タイトルなんですけど
タイトルでそのままだったんですけど
私は切望と割愛の世界に達する方法だったような気がして
これワールドアタッチメントだって書いてあるんですけど
それがちょっと割愛の世界についてだと思いますけど
それと 学会の 学会のスローガンをなんかちょっと今大学会議で
ドントブレないんでちょっと
ありがとうございます
難しそうな話じゃないんだ
時間がね 一回二回経験したから
心を清らかにする人が幸せであるっていう風に読めたと思ったんですけど
心 を清らかにする人が幸せであるのがいいんじゃないかという二つ意見が分かれてるんですけど
どちらがいいですかね
なんか集中が来てないんで
とりあえず先生に聞いてみましたんですけど
心を清らかにするのが幸せであるの方がなんとなくまああのフレーズとしては通ると思うんですけど
文法的に言うと心を清らかにする人が幸せであるのがいいんじゃない
日本語的にもどっちでも大丈夫でしょ
どちらでも大丈夫ですけど
あえて お願いします 心をって
この感じがありますから
ちょっと よいしょ